of all the people I know of all the
people I know in my life for her you
might have be the one that was most
excited about the new Star Wars movie
and so I thought there's a new you built
the religion around though and I think I
think you're one of the first people to
see it yeah what did you think of Star
Wars The Force awakens and don't hold
back all right
here's what happened with Star Wars okay
Star Wars Episode four five and six the
first ones the first ones
those were your 1970s drinking snortin
coke buddies you'd get together had fun
you got hookers together they were great
they then then they sobered up started
getting into like government and how
does Congress work a little libertarian
on the lecturing you about you know
there's actually these Maite chlorines
and I'm trying to eat healthier and then
you're like wait what what I thought
your swords cut monsters heads off yeah
and now it's like they've gone through
an ugly divorce and they're like let's
get coke and go drinking again awakens
like who a line of coke off of the
lightsaber look I do it right yeah
which really wouldn't work when you
think about it yeah or would it be
amazing yeah
which camera do I turn to hang on let me
try that again or but I need to do a
turn okay Keith I'm wondering or would
it be amazing most guests don't direct
their own segment I really I know camera
right now hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy japanese
pornography